ohne langsam herum zu reden ich will mir
selber airports bauen das sind über
teure in ear kopfhörer von apple und der
grund warum ich selbst welche bauen will
ist nicht etwa um geld zu sparen dass
man sich vielleicht denken könnte auch
wenn das glaube ich schon viel billiger
ist sich selbst zu machen werden wir
rausfinden aber der wahre grund ist ich
habe keine ohren und deshalb auch super
keine gehörgänge die noch nie in ihrem
leben auf kopfhörer getroffen sind die
da drin bleiben würden wenn ich sport
mache oder so ich bin wegen schon alles
mögen probiert aufsätze und war dann
sofort einmal selbst das ding hier drin
ohne ausnahme zu groß für mein ohr also
gar nichts anderes übrig als eins zu
eins airports zu bauen und die nach oben
drauf maßgeschneidert zu machen und
vielleicht endlich kommt mit dem wir
nicht ständig aus frei
dieses video wird unterstützt von
cyberghost vpn als erstes muss ich
herausfinden was in airports eigentlich
drin ist und wie bluetooth
in-ear-kopfhörer allgemein überhaupt
funktioniert dafür könnte man jetzt
stundenlang in fachliteratur blättern
oder man holt sich zum experimentieren
einfach die günstigsten kabellosen
kopfhörer auf dem markt für 15 euro und
wirft einen blick hinein und hier ist
unser büro kopfhörer wie kriegt denn
jetzt möglichst schonend auf ja mal
schauen und das was sie
ja okay da geht schon was das wird
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen verklebt
sein oh ja okay das definitiv verklebt
und wird ja sogar die dinger oha das ja
geil die platine ist aber auch genauso
groß wie dieses ding ist nutzt wirklich
die maximal fläche ausbringen schweiz
darunter ist oder wo
[Musik]
ich lust also hat zu eröffnen die pille
reich zu beschädigen geht hat einfach
gar nicht die teile im inneren bleibt
natürlich aber unbeschädigt gute jetzt
hier vorsichtig allerdings abreißt weil
es hier einmal der lautsprecher
angeklebt krass die kleinen der
lautsprecher ist generell in zehn wie
kleine techniker marias wo die batterie
schaumstoff und hier ist die platine
eben drin im krieg die jetzt raus das
blaue licht wirkt irgendwie so hart
treffen themenbild bestreiten darüber
wird dann in der hülle aufgeladen so und
jetzt kannst hier raus schieben
hoffentlich perfekt das teil ist dann
eigentlich funktioniert er auch so passt
das hat einfach meine neuen airports
kassel
hier ist einfach ein knopf
das hier sind knopf ist das crazy im
inneren haben wir also kabel ein akku
einen chip samt knopf und lade pins und
natürlich lautsprecher und genauso
wichtig wie das innere ist hier
selbstverständlich auch das äußere und
da hat jeder so seine vorlieben diese
billig dinge zum beispiel sind nicht
mehr so richtig in ihr verhalten bei mir
auch nicht wirklich und dass wir vorne
superscharf kann sich nun einfach nicht
mehr bereit machen deswegen will ich
also eins zu eins die geschwungene form
der original ipods und auch mit diesem
gummi dozieren dran nur dass ich das
jetzt eben komplett selbst herstellen
und auf mein ohr anpassen muss zunächst
erstelle ich also ein 3d modell und das
ist bei so einem kurvigen teil super
schwierig aber zum glück gibt es vom
hersteller fast vollständige technische
zeichnungen aller produkte und damit
auch von dem was wir brauchen genau wie
die originalen airports werden meine aus
drei teilen zusammengesetzt dem
hauptteil einer kleinen kappe ganz unten
und dem kopf und um dieses kopfteil
kümmere ich mich als erstes
normalerweise mache ich diese dinge mit
einem 3d drucker und so wenn man es auch
heute machen allerdings heute nicht mit
einem so genannten fdm drucker der nicht
immer benutzt die herausforderung wird
es nämlich sein die typisch glatte weiße
oberfläche der kopfhörer nachzustellen
die 3d drucker die ich für projekte wie
zb meinen selbst gebauten stromgenerator
genutzt habe schmerzen ebene für ebene
eine kleine kunststoff spur übereinander
bis ein gegenstand entsteht auch wenn
das in der regel am schnellsten und am
besten ist für meine projekte fallen bei
genauer betrachtung die einzelnen
gelobten spielen schon sehr auf anders
ist das bei einem hearts 3d drucker bei
dem in einem becken aus flüssigem
kunstharz eben dieses durch uv-licht nur
an den gewünschten stellen ausgehärtet
wird und dass ebene für ebene und davon
habe ich mir vor kurzem ein sehr
günstiges modell zugelegt auch wenn das
glaubt mir fielen aufwendiger ist sieht
unser erster test damit schon richtig
richtig krass ausser man kennt keine
spuren das sieht einmal aus wie ein
fertiges produkt lassen sich direkt
kaufen kann und die oberfläche ähnelt
den airports schon extrem der nachteil
ist das ganze ein gutes stück
aufwendiger ist und man bald diese
eklige und extrem wichtige und stinkende
flüssigkeit braucht weswegen ich erstmal
aktivkohlefilter
draußen
und ein fenster aufmacht
pakistan
danken darauf
[Musik]
warten strom
die luft ist rein er konnte jetzt ein
usb stick hier rein ich will mir hier
das ding aus der sich ausdrucken will
und
[Musik]
dann taucht er das ding rein
fortsetzung service frei haus machte
jetzt schicht geschichts und 3d objekt
guten morgen soll der druck hat jetzt
ungefähr eine stunde gedauert nachdem
entfernungs prozess und ordentlich und
sehr gründlichen waschgang weil es ja
super giftig ist sieht dieses talent so
aus
[Musik]
ich finde es mega nämlich ein bisschen
an so einem flotten gern so sehen jetzt
diese support strukturen aus die dafür
gesorgt haben dass das ding halt hält
jetzt relativ dünn und dafür eigentlich
auch ziemlich stabil und die mache jetzt
ab und zwar noch bevor ich das ding
jetzt aus herten werde gleich im
uv-licht weil die weicher das ist das
leicht ab
[Musik]
und ich glaube ich mal was kaputt
gemacht ja habe ich das kann jetzt ab in
die uv kammer würde auch nie gesagt
sonnenlicht gehen
zwei minuten und letzte
[Musik]
so jetzt ist das gute stück ausgehärtet
ist nicht mehr so flexibel wie vorn aber
immer noch ein gutes stück und dann das
ding hier jetzt bisschen beschädigt
wurde leider und da ist auch ein
stückchen zu dünn ist ein bisschen so
transparent und auch ein bisschen zu
leicht verformbar würde ich sagen mach
ich das nochmal uns direkt auch den rest
der airports wie sie bruder
bis sich damit unterwegs musik hören
oder netflix schonen kann wird aber noch
eine weile dauern apropos netflix
wusstet ihr dass man mit einem vpn also
zum beispiel unserem heutigen sponsor
cyberghost vpn serien und filme
anschauen kann die in deutschland nicht
verfügbar sind ein vpn verschlüsselt
nämlich nicht nur alles damit die anonym
sondern euer gesamt der datenverkehr
läuft damit über eine andere ip-adresse
in einem land eurer wahl salvador vpn
bietet ihr 7200 server aus 90 ländern
zur auswahl womit die glocken von
netflix diesen die platz und 33 weiteren
streaming anbieter ganz einfach umgehen
und filme und serien aus anderen ländern
schauen könnt
in deutschland könnte zum beispiel sogar
wieder formel 1 kostenlos schauen auf
der webseite des österreichischen
senders orf der sonst deutsche ohne vpn
aussperrte sahlberg auf 238 millionen
nutzer fünf sterne auf fast 24 7 support
und eine strikte naujoks policy server
gibt es für alle geräte also auch fürs
handy und ihr könnt es mit einem account
sogar mit bis zu sieben leuten teilen
wenn die cyber ghost vpn jetzt
ausprobieren möchte bekommt ihr über den
link in der video beschreibung 85
prozent rabatt und zahlt dadurch nur
einen euro 84 im monat und dank der 45
tage geld-zurück-garantie ist das ganze
auch komplett risikofrei
[Musik]
also das ist schon super will aus ich
bin gespannt ist man zusammen der andere
hälfte jetzt muss ich das erste volle
unterstützung streben trennen
[Musik]
schon zusammen sieht das dann so aus
und das ist schon echt super nah dran es
ab in die herzkammer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so hinweis verschwinden machen ich davon
jetzt direkt drei stück linke und rechte
fahre
[Musik]
das kann sich nun aber wirklich sehen
lassen mit etwas schleifen und ganz viel
geduld haben wir nun perfekte airport
höhe
also jetzt noch fehlt sind diese
gummiteile hier vorne und da war ich mir
so ein spezielles zeug gekauft dass das
3d gedruckte zu gummi mäßig macht das
hat er letztlich so gute bewertungen im
netz allerdings hatten auch keine andere
wahl darum mich davon jetzt mal ein
bisschen mit rein
[Musik]
während ich den drucker einmal durchs
zimmer transportiert habe ist mir leider
etwas dummes passiert ich hab den
drucker zu schnell bewegt wodurch das
harz aus dem becken geschwappt ist und
einmal über den kompletten drucker
geflossen ist und die sauerei muss jetzt
erst mal beseitigt werden bevor ich die
gummiteile zum ersten mal testen kann
was für eine sauerei mal schauen wie das
jetzt geworden ist es ist flexibel als
es könnte noch flexibler sein aber es
ist schon super flexibel ich hatte
einfach so ein gummi teils spricht die
maler ab
das hat einfach super flexibel die frage
ist ob das schon passen würde oder ob
das noch dünner werden muss sowohl frage
ist ob das jetzt schon hier drauf passt
oder ob ich das mir versprochen habe
ja es passt auf ein sehr schwieriges
muss genau aufpassen
ich bin aber vorbereitet und weiß dass
so eine substanz ja genau und zwar mit
ich jetzt quasi hier im verhältnis eins
zu eins das zeug zusammen amazon ding
und ein mal so'n ding so
so das macht man ja zusammen denkt
niemals vertauschen erwirbt ich glaube
ich hab's treffen tauschen so und ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt denken könnt
aber das ding muss ich jetzt mein ohr
stecken
zehn minuten und dann habe ich perfekte
apropos im ohr
[Musik]
ist ja gar nicht mal so angenehm
ruhigen embryo ist ob das mein ohr ist
einfach das ist ja echt krass na gut
dann gehe ich das ganze optimieren hier
kann man gut erkennen dass mein
gehörgang mit circa drei millimeter
sogar dünner ist als der unwegsame
innere kern der in ear aufsätze kein
wunder also dass die da nicht rein
passen zum glück kann ich die aufsätze
am pc genau auf meine bedürfnisse
anpassen bis ins letzte detail und
anschließend ganz einfach ausdrucken
naja zumindest habe ich mir das so
gedacht das was ich vorher gemacht habe
dem 3d drucker hat den so ein bisschen
gegrillt ganz egal der usb stick hier
blinkt zwar aber geht nichts und dann
der andere usb stick mit dem gleichen
dateien glaube da geht auch gar nix
irgendwie ist da schauen wir dass
physiker darüber jetzt drin zog so
unnötig jetzt
einmal alle usb sticks durch die ich
habe ok nico ich weiß nicht wieso dass
das gab die anderen beiden habe ich
vorhin schon mal funktioniert aber ich
werde mich da nicht das projekt gerettet
gestern nacht habe ich ungefähr 45 mal
versucht das selbe link zu drücken aber
es hat nicht geklappt was gedruckt ist
immer von dieser druckplatte
runtergefallen damit so etwas in den
einstellungen geändert hoffentlich
funktioniert in der zwischenzeit können
wir uns schon mal um die elektronik da
müssen wir ein bisschen shoppen gehen
die frage ist wo kriegt man öffentlich
so kleine elektronik her miniatur
lautsprecher sehr höchstens ein
zentimeter durchmesser platz die sind
obwohl aus und ist einzig aus wie groß
sind die 1,6 zentimeter auch viel zu
groß 15 20 nach einiger zeit stellt sich
heraus dass es quasi unmöglich ist an
die winzig kleinen einzelteile von in
ear kopfhörern zu gelangen selbst das
was am leichtesten zu finden sein sollte
die lautsprecher bekommt man nur wenn
man direkt 100 am stück kauf also muss
ich mit dem arbeiten was ich habe die 15
euro kopfhörer vom anfang in seine
einzelteile zerlegen sie passend machen
für meine airports und dann zusammen
löten
[Musik]
so jetzt wird's ernst
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt so eine gute
idee ist dass abzutrennen wir das teil
an ist aber ich kann auch nicht
ausmachen
allen dann schnell zweiten unten sind
die lautsprecher und oben ist der akku
und ich musste es auch verkehrt rum rein
machen und wo sich einmal alles komplett
um verkabeln
[Musik]
ja ich sehe das gar nicht den augen das
richtig zu erkennen ob das jetzt
geklappt hat oder nicht aber scheint zu
funktionieren
das ist so winzig
[Musik]
damit
ist noch nicht ganz aus wie ein airport
und dafür brauchen wir jetzt noch die
andere hälfte ob ich mal schauen wie ihr
euch das treten kann dass man das wird
also im idealfall ab jetzt muss ich
gehört ich höre sie auf jeden fall dann
jetzt dass man anzukleben
endspurt schwarz zu kurz die kontakte
daran und ist nun ja die urteile jetzt
endlich doppel knapp dran und wieder
geklappt haben sich richtig krass an und
die sind super verformbar die selbst rg
extrem elastisch und sparen wir sind
jetzt herausfinden auf den teuren
klassen sagt und da ist der in ear
kopfhörer der sogar in mein ohr rein
passt ich hätte damit jetzt mal musik
also die qualität ist nicht ganz so gut
wie beim online hat muss man zugeben
aber wenigstens haben wir die jetzt beim
sport nicht mehr druck seien mäßig sind
sie natürlich ziemlich exakt arena dran
mit dem größten und offensichtlichste
unterschied der farbe es ist krass die
ganze zeit also ich daran gearbeitet hat
sei diese helfen heute schon ziemlich
krass weiß aus aber jetzt erstmals mit
der ganzen technik runter und natürlich
auch generell schon ohne technik in die
originalen einfach schon echt extrem
krasse weiß und damit kann ich nicht
mithalten wenn man es richtig echt und
knall weiß haben möchte könne man jetzt
noch hier zum beispiel farbe drauf
machen und das dann halt einmal
schneeweiß pinseln damit kommt die farbe
schon viel mehr als original der krass
ich habe den hinweis sehr sehr viel
gelernt zum beispiel was in so in ear
kopfhörern drin ist ich habe so viel
geld wie noch nie zuvor und vor allem
habe ich gelernt wie man mit hearts 3d
druck und zwar richtig krasse feine und
glatte oberfläche machen kann und dass
wir mit sicherheit vor allem für andere
bauprojekte noch richtig gebrauchen
diese bauprojekte kommen übrigens immer
mehr und mehr auf meinem zweiten alten
renault genau so wieder heute ein video
kam in dem ich eine automatische
murmelbahn mit kurbel antrieb und aufzug
und spitalrat mechanismus und zwar noch
nicht gebaut habt könnt ihr euch nach
dem video gerne anschauen preislich sind
wir bei den do it yourself airports was
material an kosten angeht zusammen mit
den billigen hier dieser verwendet habe
übrigens bei 18 eur 60 hast du nicht mal
ein zehntel von den originalen
allerdings sind sie weiß ich auch nicht
ganz so gut vielen dank an cyberghost
unterstützung von diesem video mit
saerbeck aus könnt ihr auch geblockt der
inhalte im internet zugreifen und eure
daten schützen den link zum vpn mit 85
prozent rabatt zu 1 euro führen 80 pro
monat und vier monaten gratis findet ihr
eine video beschreibung wenn euch das
video gefallen hat abonniert gerne
diesen kanal und dann sehen wir zunächst
mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]